hello everyone welcome to a
another wolfram language design review
this is part of our language
completeness and consistency
series
and we have a variety of topics
padding so there are probably cases that
you know you may have in mind that
aren't covered by this but
you know i want to get to other things
on the agenda as well
um
but these are the three most recent
cases i think that you've sent
of padding issues oh
these are crazy
just bonkers
so there
yeah there's a little summary
well overall summary i don't know how
illuminating it is but
um
okay and the short answer is you know
i mean the base at least two of the
three come down to
you know how we measure things weren't
accurate
um well we faked something sometime
you know like our wonderful discussion
which isn't our fault about font sizes
and things
you know if we fake how what the actual
bounding box of a graphic is
because we don't want you know for
example the bounding
uh frame to be sliced or something
so we fake it slightly that fakery is
going to compound
yes
go ahead
right okay so this first one is
i think you know a consequence of you
know
you know a change a few years ago
um
with spherical region and you know
related to shrink wrap
um
and then it's just a case of
you know when you know when i'm yeah so
spherical region is automatic by default
which
is one behavior when the graphic is on
its own sort of
and
you know
is
false when it's on its own and true when
it's in certain constructs
and so i measure it and it's false and
then you know when it gets deployed it
ends up being true
and so i just need to
so it's a bug yeah yeah it's a bug it's
brett's code just measured the wrong
thing effectively
okay so that's going to fix
the 3d graphic absurd over spacing is
that correct and
the same fix i should be able to make
for image 3d which i think you said you
were also seeing it
yes
um okay all right so that's that case so
we that one was just a bug fine
but now there are lots of other cases
where
i think it's graphics with frames with
labels and things like that where it
just kind of goes like this what the
hell happened here
yeah what the hell happened here this
one i don't fully understand yet
um
yeah well i mean i suspect you
mismeasured something again go ahead
it's gonna say i'm certain of that
because if you look at the thing below
um
you know it's still not perfect but it's
much closer
um and again it's
you know
somehow image that well i mean image
size multipliers is
coming into play somehow but this is a
case where
it's labeled of graphic
and so the usual tools
don't apply well or they don't currently
apply the absolute options stuff doesn't
probably propagate through labeled
right
it doesn't even make sense
right i mean it would return labeled
options
yeah i understand
um
i think the real
solution for this case
is
you know
to
treat the you know you know to tear the
label apart and treat the two parts
separately
as you as you say i mean look
this is a good example because you know
you've got to be able to i mean this is
clearly wrong so let's figure out how we
fix it
uh i mean to me it looks like it
probably picked up so i god knows what
it did but i mean you'll have just have
to analyze it i don't know
and the question in the end is
how much space should there be by
default in a bunch of these situations
and
you know i think we may in the end have
to come up with a more
nuanced padding description
than we've had
to cover all these things
um
but maybe we should first track down the
bugs have you
let's see
how would we detect
um
yeah okay so look here's the thing
anytime
that
somebody could look through code of mine
like from posts that i've written and so
on and look for spacing's arrow a
negative number
okay
that is always a good indication that
you're
resorting to extreme measures yeah that
something's going horribly wrong because
i think there's many many graphics grid
examples of that
etc
so i mean somebody maybe could um
uh somebody could just
try and take
i think kristen is i think handling
those
those things but could try and take that
and do some kind of um
uh
um
um
uh
right i mean and yeah and just sort of
detect those cases i mean so like that
one that's in the middle of the screen
right now where there's like huge and
increasing amounts of
white space between the plots
if you like double click on one of the
plots
you'll get the you know rectangle that
is the inset that i'm putting things
into this is completely bonkers
and
yeah
look even looking at that inset look at
the space above it
there's something wrong with that
well isn't that just spacings
no no space above it right there
that space is spacings
of a graphics grid
right it wasn't right
okay
if you set spacings goes to zero in the
graphics row there then that space above
and below presumably should not be there
i thought spacings was was giving the
the horizontal space here
it's getting both right
please tell me it didn't increase not a
change
let's try the list zero zero
i don't remember offhand
graphics row is special casing
that setting but
yeah so
well it's a little bit weird i mean it
should okay so that so you're right i
never would have guessed that i never
would have guessed that the graphics row
really actually has a
a inter-row spacing parameter
somehow
hidden
underwater in it
well i mean it
yeah yeah i mean of course the problem
is graphics row is just a specialization
of graphics grid yeah but you know that
but your average user including me
doesn't necessarily know that
i might suspect it
but that's only because i know the
history of its implementation and things
well i mean
i i would expect graphics for a graphics
column and graphics grid to be closely
related i know that but one would but i
mean i would also expect rogue column
and grid to be closely related we know
that's not true
yes well right
so okay but in any case
you know just all of this random i don't
think there should be spaces above and
below here okay sorry it just shouldn't
be like that it's just wrong
i mean
you know i mean i i don't know that it's
just wrong
i mean i i i was i tried unsuccess
unsuccessfully
last week to
you know basically do
what was it graphics row of graphics
column
you know graphics wrote a bunch of
graphics columns
um
and
you know in an application like that
you know i wouldn't want
no you don't it's a graphics row it fits
things
let me just clarify
uh
so
you are claiming that there should be no
spacing in graphics row
but that this would be different from
for example
a graphics grid that has only one row in
it absolutely
absolutely it's not the same thing
just like a
you know yes absolutely not the same
john there are already places where
graphics rose different from one row
graphics grid i i'm not it's
let me be clear i'm not
fighting or arguing or complaining i'm
just
okay
all right
okay so look i i'm just i'm encouraging
you to go look at other places where
negative spacings have been used i would
also look at places where i know i think
brad clee has been doing this a bit
recently using row of graphics because
graphics row is so hopeless
you should he he's of something of a
critic of graphics row could talk to him
i mean i'm a critic of graphics pro
well
your solution was to remove graphics uh
well from the system was it not
yeah but but okay but but we we need
graphics though it's very useful
functionality ability to have something
where you can you know take the whole
thing and shrink it it's really useful
right
but yes but i mean
you know and it's different from the row
functionality it just has to be gotten
right which this isn't so so why why is
the white space decreasing there right
it's basically they're staying the same
height
and the white space is decreasing
cut knobs i mean this is what because
yeah the contents of that inset isn't
resizing right now
um
because it's not resizable
um which i mean earlier today i found an
old email from john
on a thread about this but i haven't
all right you're gonna sort it out
you're gonna sort it out
at the middle case i don't think it
would be there
which guys
[Music]
this is the middle case is another
measuring thing
you know you know it's gonna get you
know maybe a little bit hairy but
um so in case two you're claiming is
just the bottom
it's essentially just a bug
um
all right look i think we've got an
infestation of bugs
here so let's get you know and i had no
idea that that extra space above and
below that's crazy is a vestigial you
know it's the thing used to walk on the
land but now it only needs fins but it
still has one of its legs
the um
uh
i was gonna say i'm reminded that you
know apparently some people have like a
little dimple in their ear that's
a remnant of gills
really okay fair enough well this is
this is our version of that so let's get
rid of it
the i mean it's i had no idea i mean
this is that that's been there for years
that's crazy okay but
you know so let's do another iteration
of this let's look
at uh please talk to brad clee because i
think he's got a bunch of examples
and
you know sounds like this may just be a
bug fixing issue
but we may also run into things probably
80 bug fixing and 20 percent
you know needing to figure out
you know some alternative mechanism for
something fine we'll come to that when
we come to that yep all right let's move
on
absolute options
what was the blast out of woo
i like absolute options
okay
i think more things should support
absolute options
yeah well when they don't lie
right so
uh
you know
this is
mostly documentation maybe a little bit
of implementation
um so i have here sort of suggested
replacement for the main usage
and then
sort of the table i've been able to
collect of
you know things that do support it or
might support it
um
and so
you know
question one is
you know are we you know
what do we think about the this uh
okay hold on give us the absolute
settings
i wouldn't use settings as a word like
that because we've also got a settings
you know for dynamic we also got the
notion of settings for a dynamic
i would say absolute
should it be
okay i mean
i'm gonna
say
first off that remember that absolute
options returns the entire option
which i'm going to propose that we
should also have like an absolute option
values
but we don't have to decide that today
do we have option we have option value
but that's pattern matching construct
right
but does that mean that that
happens
it's well it's
it's sort of it's not exactly pattern
matching but it is used in down values
right to
resolve
but if we said option value
i mean if we said if we had a thing
where you know we had option value of
graphics of disk or whatever
comma
is this obviously stupid to say
to to essentially have a a pre-first
okay so this
okay doesn't work but this
i would argue that first thing should
work because this is going to work
why not have this work as well i
well i don't i mean there can
there can already be
you know sort of general expressions in
that first argument right it can be
a list of
options it can be
a combination of hits and listen options
i i think
can it wait a minute can it
yes
let me look
uh fourth note i believe
yeah you can mix or match
pretty extensively what can you mix and
match symbols and lists of options
okay but that's still not the same
signatures this type of thing no
no but i
i i mean this is right this this i think
that i think this is just sort of really
wrong right it just
it's
you know you have sort of an explicit
um
well i mean i mean
it's not entirely different i i mean to
the extent that you know so stephen if
you do option value of graphics comma
plot range
i just did that oh so right you know so
that is sort of equivalently tied to
option value of options of graphics
comma plot range
and so you know i could argue that
option value already essentially will
wrap
well i guess things and options
which is all that it would have to do
for that first example to work
but
well but right but if if you do
um
[Music]
you do options of graphics of this
bracket bracket right it returns an
empty list
right
right you would have to be list of
options of graphics of disk and then
comma
graphics or something to get
to get what
um
to get all in that case
well so
you're well you're you're missing
um
[Music]
yeah you're you're missing the energy
the problem is that it didn't explicitly
have if this would happen
you need you need an empty list in the
second
and that's not going to work
yeah you need an empty list in the
um
that's that it's in the wrong place it's
not inside the graphics that bought this
oh oh okay that's just stupid yeah
but even accepting that i don't think
that this is going to do anything except
it's going to work
um right yeah so this works
um
was this sent to me oh was this in
dropbox or not
yes
i think i have to separately put it
there
it was it goes in lcc
that's right lcc
okay
okay
go ahead
right i mean right and so right and what
happens if you then give the
um
well i'm arguing
i'm arguing this should work but but
let's not cross that bridge because the
question you're asking here
is
um
right so i'm basically
eliminating the fourth usage and sort of
yeah i understand we're refining what
the description of the first
i don't think you should say visual
interface object because i can imagine
this being used for some random
blob you know some machine learning blob
or something
well i guess
right well then the question is you know
should it work with you know an
integrate
well
maybe yes if it came back in a if the
thing came back in a in a
you know nounified form
i would say what i would do here is say
obj here
instead of exper
and says gives the absolute absolute
yes the question is is uh is the
[Music]
you know
machine learning blob
likely to have
implicit option values and if so how
would it be resolved
i think yes on the implicit option
values for sure
resolution i don't know i mean i think
that the the information function
often resolves some of those things
okay
so
i mean i would say absolute options of
obj
uh
gives
the list of
absolute
why don't you just say gives the
absolute
you know settings of options
in
the graphics or other object
obj
okay well
i guess
why
why are we singling out graphics then
well then let's not that's not i mean we
could say
because this is a whole
just because it gives some hope of being
able to say i mean this is a this is a
random
collection
it's not it's really not that random
it's
it is
which is why i wrote the note the way i
did it's
you know things coming
first of all it's basically all things
that come from the front end and second
of all it's either front end objects
directly which are the last four
or it's things that are essentially
graphics like okay let me make a
suggestion
um
gives the absolute settings of options
because the basic point is that the
options are sitting inside obj
that that's the unusual thing
not necessarily they pretty much
are no
not necessarily
if you do absolute options of graphics
bracket bracket you know image size
there's no option sitting inside of
graphics and yet that's going to resolve
to
you know 60 in a normal note or or there
might be an option and the option is
automatic so then it's getting this
number from
elsewhere
i would just then keep it neutral gives
the absolute settings of options
specified
for the object obj
absolute options can be used with the
following objects
types of objects
and this ordering is insane
what's this ordering doing here
well it's alphabetical of kernel things
and then alphabetical order of front-end
things which is perhaps you know was
used certainly which is useful for
discussion that may not be the correct
thing for
the final i would just i mean the front
end things are listed you know from
biggest to smallest
yeah
i guess that's true it might be useful
to just split it into two tables
yeah why not
and this one for goodness sake just
start with graphics graphics 3d because
those are the famous ones
surely graph 3d should work if graph
works
right yeah i i don't know
charles is there is there some deep
reason why
this
graph 3d is just getting tripped up
because graph 3d evaluates to graph
and so
you know it gets it's getting confused
at the moment about which options it
actually should care about okay fine
you guys will deal with this
all right
what else do we have to talk about
absolute options
right so then there's a question of
image
i mean i think we all need a tree should
i don't know if image
should that's true yes if it can it
should
i mean i i want the graphics 3d options
out of the image stuff
okay um you know which might involve you
know a little bit of
you know
stuff that isn't actually documented or
something but
right and then the i mean the only other
thing is right there there is sort of a
difference
between the colony things and the front
entrance right if you give it
uh if you ask for a front end thing
then it will tell you the the god's
honest truth because it's going to go to
the front end and say oh i'm looking at
this object here's
how the front end is running with
now if you do
a kernel object
then it's going to sort of try to embed
it in a notebook and get some of the
things right
in fact i don't know exactly how it
works maybe brett wants to speak to that
but for example
you know as i noted in the agenda if you
do
graphics and you change the style sheet
it'll pick up the changes to plot range
but if you make your notebook super
narrow so that the default value of
automatic is now smaller than specified
by the style sheet
that won't get picked up if you do
absolute options of graphics and the
question is
is this something we want to document is
this
is
some things we consider bugs is this
something we just sort of
live with
i think i classify it as implementation
detail
um
i don't remember offhand what it's doing
i mean i think it's
should be following the behavior of
rasterize
pretty closely in terms of
how it
it's propagating style
stuff
um
but
i wasn't fully paying attention this
did you want it uh do i need to
understand this
right so
do
you know absolute options of graphics of
bracket bracket comma
image size
okay now make the notebook super narrow
and re-evaluate that
it's the same even though if you were to
actually evaluate that graphics
it would would have been smaller
so i do that
but then if i actually copy down and do
it again
still does that so now i'm confused if
you just do graphics bracket bracket on
its own
then what you would end up with would be
smaller
they put
okay
and now if i say of that
if i say options
what happens if i say absolute options
of
now if you do absolutely
well it'll still be wrong
but if you if you do right if you
if you right click
i don't know exactly how you get to it
but if you could reference the
you know that box object there
um i can't but i don't see how it
i don't see how to get it
john is there an easy way to get
the object box object we're pointing at
give me a second here
that's a no
yeah
right but
it's not the easiest thing
if you did that absolute options call in
the help browser
then you would get different numbers
right because that's coming from the
style sheet
not from right so what's happening here
what where is this coming from why is it
not picking up the the you know as built
version
because it doesn't have the
you know it it doesn't
have the object
as displayed in a front end
right i mean at the point that you're
querying absolute options it may not
even exist in the front end
okay you know you know but it knows
what
notebook it's evaluating so the basic
claim is this
absolute options is a final resolution
type
returner i mean in a sense
but the problem is when it is called it
cannot give a lazy result it has to give
an immediate result but that immediate
result may simply not be known
correct right unless you you have an
explicit
reference right if you use notebook
selection to select precisely the
notebook elements you're looking at then
that can be fully resolved because it's
you know right there fully resolved no i
understand but if you have a graphics
expression
who knows where that will actually end
up in the notebook this is a deeper
problem because the deeper problem is
absolute options says it's absolute but
actually absoluteness is not as absolute
as it claims
because sometimes it can't be absolute
correct
it is a good faith
attempted absolute
i know that but the issue is you don't
know that you don't know
see what i'm saying
i mean there's an argument that absolute
options should have more controls like a
third argument or something that
basically says
either do the best you can
or
let me know if you don't know
like it says
uh you know indeterminate or some such
other thing
i kind of think that's what we have to
do either that or in a future world when
we have if you know when we have
laziness fully
eagerly
implemented so to speak that it could
return
some kind of lazy object
because it's all it that's what it
should do i mean this is just wrong
that image size result
see what i'm saying it's unresolvable
there are some things where absolute
options successfully resolves
right the plot range it successfully
resolves but the image size it does not
and it should it should make that clear
does that make sense
i mean i bet i've got bugs in my code
from assuming that this was actually the
actual image size
making sense
right although i guess the question is
how much will we break by just returning
indeterminate now i don't think we
should do that by default but i think we
should have i think we should have
a third element of absolute options that
says you know be honest
you know that's something
something we could think about yeah
i think it's the i think that's the
escape valve for this because we can get
to different levels of honesty because
you know for example another thing could
happen is you could know what the value
is up to some font metrics that you
don't know
see what i'm saying
so you can have a pretty good idea it's
about 300 pixels but it might actually
be 307 pixels
and for some purposes just knowing 300
is good enough
john do you have any comments on this
sorry i was
still trying to get it to work on a box
object which i had i was able to get the
box object and then things didn't work
as i expected so i think there's yeah
there are bugs
not in bugs
yes yes okay all right anyway did you
should i repeat the issue
i'm just yeah sorry i'm just saying that
there are different levels of
you know certainty about absolute
options i claim
there is a we can resolve it we can nail
it the answer is 17.
okay
there's sorry we just have no idea it
depends what shape of window you're in
yeah
and there's i claim some intermediate
cases where it is resolvable up to the
details of font metric data for example
let's see i can imagine a case where you
know it's 12 point type
and you can kind of guess it's roughly
this height but the actual descenders
and that font might be different
do you see that or not
i don't think your third case is really
an issue okay fine
all right well then then then there are
two possible values for the third
argument
one is
um
you know it's
give me the best you can now
and the other is
wait if you have to
and possibly the weight if you have to
will return some kind of
promissory object or lazy object at some
point in the future
make sense
can we move on
we can move on
good
okay
i think it's a i think it's a decent
approach to this because it gets us out
of this box
all right fine shortest tour
right so you are complaining about some
at some point that you what you really
want how the fine shortest tour is the
length of the tour no i don't want the
length i actually must never want the
length i usually want the elements
oh okay
okay
look i think the right solution to this
is
what's the second argument to find
shortest tour
if it has one
why is this not why is this not giving
me a raft look at this
i'm up a creek without a raft so to
speak well there's always double click
look at this no no i i don't care about
i i care about the bug look at this john
yeah you see this
does it happen with other
symbols
it's just not doing it for anything
right now
what the hell
do you have a delay maybe
no my rafts are broken
in a new note
try a different notebook
i'm going to go to 125 see if that makes
any difference
the rafts are gone
if you go back to 100
all right no i don't think it won't make
any difference
let me just try new
am i in the prototype build
you might be given that color and i
don't think that clothing has been
launched
no no that's probably my specific
setting
oh this is prototype built so this must
just be a bug in the prototype build
could be i'll
take a look
okay now remind me how to get this
without a um double click shift command
s
well that's like ancient history
right so fast shot tester take a list
three argument the last two are the
starting and end vertex
so there's no way to control the format
of the output
and i don't think we should do that
specifically for this we have a set of
uh functions find short test path
function test two or functional test
cycles which are all the same family
sorry say that again
um i say we right after the i mean we
added new functions which in the same
family financial test part
cycle tour and search okay fine but
answer me the following question
okay i find it really inelegant that i
have to say
this
to
you know it's not really element two
there's no two about it
it's the path
so that's my problem charles what what
do you suggest
uh and i agree i mean this is uh we just
kept that because of backward
compatibility and compatibility
for all the new functions we actually
return you know the the path or the
vertex you want
so
at the time the point is we can
introduce a new you know new function
for that
so you're saying fine shortest so what
are the others find shortest uh five
shortest paths you know find a tonion
part cycles well fine shortest path
please expect to graph
what threshold tests also take a graph
no i understand that oh but they
returned those returnograph rather than
that's
right we need to use the new summary box
probably something i need to do yeah
okay but in any case yes that's it
that's a avery that's a thing to track
please
um yep i got it
so
let's see so the basic point
if if this had an actual path you know
fine it would just give the path
so we got a screwy situation here the
tour
that fine shortest path would be
you know that would be graph distance
right to give the distance
correct
um
yes
close
i mean that's the length of the shortest
path is it not
minus one whatever
okay so we got an ugly duckling here
we've got this one
what's the other one find shortest tour
and
so we have a find a miltonian part for
example which also return
a path
we have found the metronian cycle we
have um
yeah okay so we have a so find shortest
tour is the odd fish out
because it oh boy what a mess
what a freaking mess
what would happen
if we called this
find shortest cycle
if we had that be the thing that just
returns the cycle there
well it's not a cycle right it doesn't
close
yes it does look at it one to one
it's a tour it closes
what's the other thing that we do we do
the other thing that we can do on geo
that isn't fine shorter store what's the
other what's the other one of those
did you understand what i'm asking
which of these also works on geo
i know that for a standard fine short
test tool to work on auntie and such but
i don't remember maybe just your team
can say maybe jose is here can see more
about it i don't remember anything
related to jio
i think it's fine shutter store the one
that works in
is that the only one
as far as i know yes
you take entities on search right within
the d2
although
looking at
i mean if you look at the
basic examples they're
sort of oh well still using country data
oh god's freaking sick that should get
fixed
okay listen look here's my suggestion
that
fine shortest tour
that we have a fine shortest cycle
that
i don't understand what difference
between that and fine cycle is but find
shortest cycle
would be
the thing for graphs
you see what i'm saying and that we
somehow find a way to tease apart
the
sort of traveling salesman to our thing
on
you know
geo and data
and separate its results
separate from
do do you get what i'm saying i don't
understand why fine shortest tour
has two things here i thought it was a
tour comes back to where it starts from
again
no so
so this is another
you know custom version of financial
testosterone where you can actually
you know
add another constraint in that on this
optimization problem where you want to
minimize the link between those two
specific vertices
okay this is lovely all right fine but
we've got a big model puddle here
because we've got like
four different functions that are all in
the same function so let's enumerate
what the functions actually are okay
you've got find shortest cycle which is
a graph theoretic function if i'm not
wrong
theoretically in principle they're all
actually just graph because
even the other cases behind the scene
you actually have the curve
which are in the complete graph in those
cases
that's why we decided at the time to not
have a specific new function for graphs
sandra on our livestream has just
suggests a
a a saving idea here which is why not do
the thing we've done for nearest and so
on and just have
something like this where we go arrow
path
or arrow length
there
why not same as we do for nearest
that makes sense to people
isn't it the nearest controlling like
the distance function not what you help
with no no no no it's not it's
controlling what's your output
we do this in tech largest too
yeah it controls which which thing you
output here
see
is a this is a good way to do it
and we have a pattern for this
yep
makes sense to me thank you sander
you saved possibility of several other
functions i noticed you also just sent a
message about
our previous meeting which i think
well maybe it's worth bringing up here
but i'm not sure it's quite the right
set of people that we goofed by talking
about position largest buy that it makes
absolutely no sense because you just map
the function onto the data and you get
the same result
there's no reason to have a position
largest buy
because
unlike things where to
because position
is not returning the data anymore
so it doesn't sully
like if you do take largest right
do people understand what i'm saying if
i say take largest you know whatever it
is
buy
and i say take largest buy
and then you know i don't know minus
sign or something right
i can't just map that function onto this
data because then i will have sullied
the data
do you understand what i'm saying
yep
whereas in position largest by that's
not true because position is never going
to return the data anyway
so you might as well just map over the
data and sully the data because you'll
never see it
so i think sandra is right and that
position largest buy makes no sense
position largest is fine position
largest buy simply shouldn't exist
this position largest pie makes sense as
a curried form
uh let's think about that i think barely
i mean why not just do
if you really want to go curry crazy why
don't you just say map f
list and
then position
i mean i don't think it's terribly
exciting isn't it just this and
i don't know
it doesn't doesn't float my boat to see
i don't think there's anything notable
about the currying
yeah
by the way am i getting these colors in
here because this is uh the prototype
builder because i haven't set specially
does anybody know i believe that's the
new color it's certainly reasonably
close to what i
there are colors set in the prototype
build but you might have them set
especially on your system i don't okay
i'm really liking these colors i'm
really finding them useful i'm you know
i don't know why we didn't do this
before it was just goofy we um
uh
now have we brightened the um
oops
of course that doesn't do anything
because i need to get rid of that
yeah we still need to brighten that
we should brighten this
the unmatched bracket color
right we talked about that before right
yeah i haven't been given anything from
design
okay so can somebody poke that please
who was peeming that
uh
it came up in user assistance which
would be glory but i don't remember if
that's where the
i mean because we've met multiple times
about this all right so everybody could
you teach me sorry and or
um jeremy to find out what's happened to
the various colors that are needed
yep i can follow up on that
um
okay
uh all right i think we got a solution
for this
um
i think uh
um
let's see it's basically
path
i think it's indices right i think
sander actually gave us a
suggestion here path indices in length
well length is load isn't it
i think it's
distance right i mean it would be path
which gives the actual
entries
indices which gives which positions
in the original list they are in order
right does that make sense to people
and then distance which is the distance
which in the case of a graph is the
graph distance in the case of um
what image is you know in the case of
geo it's the geographic distance right
so they're both distances
well it depends how you look at it if
you look at the path
we have geo length not geo distance
yeah i think it's length
if you look at it from a geometric point
of view it will be arc length
yes okay
but it also is
each one is a
distance i mean what worries me is that
length suggests more the you know the
number of elements in the list
yes
i i understand that
but even in the in the documentation i
think one of the last entry in file
short test tool we actually tried to
explain it that way we see the shortest
path length because of that issue
so what's your point there
that length should be fine i mean it's a
common term
so what are you suggesting you're
suggesting path length or length
length
all right fine
i just worry that length people will
think i mean particularly with your
constrained version i guess i guess
there's a fixed number of elements
whatever you do it's the same elements
you're talking about right
right
it's never a subset
all right
okay
sandra is suggesting total length
i don't i think of its length it's total
length you know i i'm not
i mean in other words
i'm not concerned about length being
misunderstood for something
length seems okay to me path versus
length
okay onward you go further
need an easier way to render graph nodes
with their names in them
right so
i don't know what if anything is
happening with this
these are some discussion points
okay so let's just frame what my issue
is okay
being told you have to write a custom
vertex shape function to do something
that's pretty obvious
doesn't sit well okay and the pretty
obvious thing is
that i want
a you know i've got a graph
and i just want to put
let's just say
okay here's an example let's say i have
a random graph
that's of course that's all i can get
let's just go something a bit more
impressive
oh for goodness sake help me
i should learn how to do this with that
okay there we go there's a nice graph
okay i want to take this graph and i
want to label every node
in this graph i want to make it so that
i've got the graph and now i want to say
vertex
labels
arrow well i can't do it with vertex
labels i think
you know what i'm what i'm what i'm
doing almost
is you know this kind of jazz
jazzinorus
so
what do you want to do you want to add
names then you do the texture function
goes to names
but it doesn't work properly
let's see
oh where is it it's not in the
autocomplete lose the game let's start
start typing
no no you already lost the game because
this stuff is all irrelevant
a capsule you know
might be relevant if it was going into
orbit but it isn't otherwise very
relevant here
why is that the autocomplete
are you telling me that there's things
which are specifically meaningful but
they didn't make into the autocomplete
hit the down arrows at the bottom
they're in the auto complete
here this was brain dead if i might say
so well where is it it wasn't even there
wasn't even there and where did the auto
complete go by the way
okay look at this i'm moving my mouse
and the auto complete goes away
that is weird
that doesn't happen to me well maybe
maybe this is uh maybe it's a prototype
build this year
it's with the raft
it's with the raft right they both got
pulled down the river
by the way i verified that the raft was
specific to the prototype build okay all
right so where is the name
yeah i don't see names anywhere there so
just not not there it's just nonsense
right so
okay
so let's try to figure out what this
okay so that you know charles is
claiming
well
if it's here it ain't documented so it
doesn't do me any good really
charles help me out
probably
you know we forgot to add it into
documentation explicitly there but
where is it
i mean
charles the fact that there's something
there but no you never told anybody
means it's not very useful
i agree and then we can actually
document it now i mean what's this
what's this what's this
oh well i copied it with the link
you copy as plain text
use shift command c to copy it and then
let me make a comment about this
shouldn't this have a click to copy if
that's what's going to happen to it
no
you might want to you might want to
copy only part of it
well but i can't
yes you can
well what if i want to copy the resource
data part well then you use shift
command c to copy it
which i'm never gonna know never gonna
know
well the fact that you don't know how to
use your own product is no i i do know
that i do know that but i you know i'm
saying
most people will not know that
let's i think that i'm not most people
yes that's what i'm claiming
all right i'll accept that
um
okay
so can we please move that to the
documentation meeting to discuss what we
should do with this because i this is a
bit to my mind a bit confusing we
probably do better
okay but it's not for this meeting
okay
so now
let's see what happens if i do this
well that's sort of lovely
if i'd known it existed
um
uh
although it's maybe a bit disappointing
that you know it's just a naked name
it is but i i think of if i presumably
if i say vertex style
i mean but god knows why this would work
to pink
what the hell
hello where's the pink
did you use label style
charles
well i have no idea what's happened with
the pink
is there a label style
i mean if i say vertex size arrow
10 or something
let's say vertex size 02 or something
like this
what happened there
oh there's a white background for this
function
yeah so i mean but vertex style
arrow
edge form
okay look this is not good whatever's
going on here is not good
okay okay no
no no this is losing it can you try
setting labels
so so let's let's let's let's hold on
for a second right we can we can argue
all the time for all details right so is
a name
and if i remember correctly we put it an
insert and we do a bunch of controls so
that it appear nice right so it's
possible that
all the additional styling you apply may
not you know
work like you expect that
so we got to fix that i mean listen this
functionality that you have vertex shape
function our own name even though you
kept it secret
it's still useful
okay
um
okay we'll make it past and make sure
that it all work correctly yeah but
it's secret right now where is it
no no we will update this page of the
tech shape function i mean we hold it 10
years ago and we added a lot of
functionality some kind of fault with
the crack while we were working on the
document you know other things
we'll make sure that there was a
duplicate there was a goof here it
stayed secret right
um
the plan is not to keep it secret it
just happened right um
okay but so let's just understand how
this should work
i mean i guess i'm happy with this if if
this can deal with the fact that
let me just do the following let's say
um
i want to get some really long names
here really long let's do this let's say
nearest neighbor graph
okay
will this do the right thing we wonder
to ourselves
maybe
maybe with with i mean again you should
be setting performance goal to quality
automatically in a case like this
because never going to work otherwise
right
well i i would consider this pretty
successful
but for the fact that we can't put in
the things that we need to put in which
are the is the you know the additional
styling
so i mean i guess my question would be
to me
unfortunately this is you know how are
you going to do that how are you going
to get
both this which seems like i think
this just seems very orthogonal to the
this other because vertex shape
functions usually this very low low and
please please when you do the
documentation put in some pure functions
here and i mean this is you know really
obscure i mean this is just like you've
hidden the main part here which is this
right
right
we will update it
fine
okay but but how do we want to do this
with um
you get what i'm saying
uh
how do you want to have
both the vertex shape function which
could be
you know normally you would combine the
positioning i mean if you have a vertex
shape function it overrules vertex style
does it not
that's why nothing's happening here it's
because vertex shape function is the
king of all vertex specifiers
yes right i think precedence yep right
so i think we don't want that i think
what we want to do
is we
want to have something else which says
to do this
so that so that vertex shape function
stays what it is right now which is the
be-all end-all you know
ultimate
controller type thing see what i'm
saying
and then instead we want something here
which just says
you know look we've we've got
i mean in a sense we've got vertex label
which says what should the label of the
vertex be
but doesn't it then has placed
as a way to specify where to put it
right
so maybe what we want is a wrapper like
placed or a setting for placed
which says to do this
because that seems like a better place
for the place thing because then if
we've got it placed we can have whatever
styling we want
like in here
in this case here i can say can i not
well i don't know what's going to happen
and if i say vertex style arrow light
pink
i don't want to fake the label
yeah which is good
that's exactly what i want
right
so this is what i want i just want a
less obscure way than doing i mean does
this work in general or is that going to
break
in this case here
do you understand my question
right right
but i mean one of the key differences
that the label don't actually know the
size and
all the appropriate placement i mean
that's the main key difference okay so
this is a mess right
look at that that's garbage right so we
need to be able to decide between these
two cases right we need to either be
able to say
we've got at the nodes here a pure node
that is its shape it's this it's that or
the other or we're using a label we're
using the label as the node designator
right which is what we're not doing here
you see what i'm saying
yes
okay so i think we've got the two
choices either
and i mean
right i mean we somehow got to be able
to switch off
the thing that says use that node
designator
i can't even tell them that one there
it's probably slicing it isn't it it
doesn't go to the right place those
those lines don't go to the right place
they go to the circle
correct
um i'm not sure about your question
look see that line it doesn't stop in
this case the line would stop at the
edge of the word in this case it goes to
the circle right yes it's the circle is
the main
you know
graphical thing right
right okay so that's the problem we've
got so what we've got is a situation
where we've got to be able to say
i think we
go ahead
i mean it's it's i mean we kind of have
partially solve it when we added the
plotting name label now so no no no no
no no it doesn't work doesn't work not
interested we've got to have an actual
way to do this
no no whatever secret secret handshake
way to do it no no i mean
we
you know what you probably want is kind
of something similar we need for we did
for protein which we can implement in
this case
actually for the text shape uh
fictitious function goes to name
so that's
it
what do we do for plotting
so if you
you know take one of the example and you
do plot them goes to
name labeled
which was one of your requests it
actually tried to
what kind of plot so sorry the graphics
sorry the graph if you build a cuff and
then you you add plot team
sorry so i make a graph like this
well here i'm making witchcraft i make
this great random right or the random
graph and then you put plot theme goes
to
what where is it
where is it
where is that
maybe a standard whole thing
in the full list no no no no no no no
this is wrong
stephen
only the primary things are listed at
least by default i have that
clearly the ones that are specific to
the rapper should be listed early
john
that is not clear
in general
you'll never find them otherwise i had
no freaking idea there was a plot theme
other than the standard ones for graph
and i don't agree with you why would we
not want to you know we could mix we
could have four of the standard ones we
could have a more there i don't know but
we got to have the custom ones otherwise
nobody's ever gonna know they're there
this is this is just a data issue we
have the the ability to do something
like this and we do it for
some options like method for example
um
right but these guys are claiming it's a
policy issue basically
yeah right
there are literally dozens if not
hundreds of
things i mean it would just not be
useful to
list them no it's high i'm not saying
you list every theme for every
rapper if this was geo list plot or
something
right you absolutely are not listing a
named
node theme
right
but um
right but
even the one well i don't know what are
how many graph hats but the ones which
are applicable to every single plot
is literally dozens if not i'm aware i'm
saying the ones that are specific to
this
need to be listed early
and can you open up the more
the arrows at the bottom because i think
those
are
the first set after
the major themes
yeah well then they're just in the wrong
order
so let's fix it
nobody's going to know if it's below the
fold nobody's going to bother to look
there because they're going to say i
know what's here it's the standard
themes that's all i need to know
so which ones do you think should be
higher
i think like a search engine it's got a
mix and match it's got to lead to you
which one are you claiming should be
higher
well you tell me what the one that's
relevant here is
the one that doesn't be here name label
i don't see it here do you see it here
well you you can't see the complete list
it would be between labeled graph i mean
larger graph large graph and index
labeled well those are the three
pretty much i mean we have four of them
including the main named label well
where's where's
where is it
where is it
charles where is it
i don't know you told me it's the main
one
but the main one seems to have been
dropped
okay
i mean that's a bug okay because all
right okay fine so there's a collection
of bugs here
that's quite nice
yeah
i didn't have no idea that that existed
no i didn't even you forgot because you
asked this stephen and we implemented
probably in the six months between when
i asked for it and when it actually got
implemented i forgot about it but that's
nice
can you look at the documentation
can i ask why vertex label function by
default doesn't look like name labeled i
mean this little outline is quite nice
whether or not you have the white
background
you mean the name version of of plot
right right when you do
it
it might look like that but it might
that might not look good and oh by the
way for goodness sake we've got to get
rid of those stupid background colors
for the entities which somehow crept in
apparently for some people but not
others
because you demanded that i i somehow i
got it wrong or i was misinterpreted
let's let's go with i got it wrong okay
okay it's a bad idea i mean if you want
to just restore the old traditional form
which was just the name with no
background i mean i presume
i think we should just do that
nick i presume that's a trivial change
to change it back
i think nick had a drop off but i can
check with him yeah i don't know if
that's a nick thing or a tony thing but
i presume that's a trivial change right
but when they change it back okay could
they please look at what caused the
change to be made to what it is now in
the first place just to
just you know to be sure that we're not
missing something
okay
i mean yeah i don't remember what the
original motivation was other than the
fact that you thought it was wrong that
the traditional poem was well and i
think i just didn't think through what
the implications of changing it would be
i think i was looking at one particular
case and it could very well be that that
one case still makes sense
it just it's seeping into everything
doesn't make sense okay well you would
be telling me
okay but let's come back to this
so
it you know you can change the name
version of vertex shape function all you
want it's still not going to solve the
problem because it's doing something
different it's not going to allow you to
have these additional overlay styles etc
etc etc this
does but has other uglinesses which we
don't want so i mean to me
sorry i was
what's the ugliness that you're
complaining about oh i mean you know
like like for example what happens if i
want the the border here to be dotted
i'm i'm toast then but in form
[Music]
of being started
what but but when you say daughter i
mean
you're assuming that you know actually
or assume that is a circle he may not be
a cycle he may not be i know i know i
know i know so what we want
is this thing
is essentially a a a
you know okay
let me let me write but what about my
suggestion that you replace pink with
directive with pink garment
i don't think it will work i mean if you
say edge form
of dotted comma pink i don't think that
will work
well i didn't say edge form well i know
but how are you going to do it i mean if
you say pink comma dotted no it's just
the directive
[Music]
i can't imagine that will work it will
make the it will make no if it did
anything wrap the dotted in edge form
okay but if it did anything it will okay
fine but my claim is that why do you
expect it to work
because it didn't work because it worked
no no it works it's fine but what i mean
is that if it doesn't work i won't claim
that is a bug
that's the kitty if you want to
manipulate the shape of an edge you have
to build it okay okay guys guys
but we're not talking about
given that there is a vertex style
thing that affects
you know tries to do something sensible
with you you know i haven't defined a
custom
uh
you know
edge
vertex shape function and there is
something called vertex style i think it
should apply the style to the elements
where it makes sense which it does in
this case
i'm answering
this question
okay i've got a suggestion here okay
vertex shape function is a fine thing
it's a low level thing it's great
there's no problem with it but it is not
a user level thing for most users okay
by the time you descended to that level
you're calculating everything you're
calculating sizes and this and that and
the other and so on i think what we need
is
a
a thing that is called i don't know what
it's called let's just make up a name
it's not a good name right
that basically is going to say for every
vertex
how should that vertex be rendered the
complete
enchilada of every vertex which means
it's a disc with a you know whatever it
is
i don't know i i mean maybe this isn't
right either
it's what we call vertex shape
but we don't have a vertex shape
we do have a vertex shape so what what
well now i'm totally confused what
happens if i now say
i see the problem is that vertex okay
all right so if we said vertex shape
arrow automatic
okay just like we can say vertex label
our automatic if we said vertex shape
our automatic means label it with its
name
isn't vertex shape goes to automatic the
default
yes that's the default
that's very unfortunate
but i mean look vertex shape arrow name
would already be a you know a good start
here
you see what i'm saying
and then maybe we get the whole solution
right if vertex shape arrow name seems
like a reasonably civilized way to get
to this
charles do you see what i'm saying
um yes
it doesn't
y vertex shape instead of vertex shape
function since vertex shape function
already has named
settings because
because
no because vertex shape function trumps
all the other things
it blows away vertex style right vertex
shape presumably does not play away a
blow away vertex style
do you see what i'm saying
well
try it and let's find out yeah let's
check let's check but i mean i think
here
so if i say
okay vertex shape
okay are they going to be pink
[Music]
well they're definitely very small
okay well that's wrong what that did is
wrong well that's not clear to me right
because you gave it a shape with a color
right what would what would it do with
an image
well fair enough okay but so let's say i
don't do that let's say vertex shape
goes to
hello there
i have to leave a moment
okay
well apart from the fact that it doesn't
have the performance goal set correctly
which should be automatic charles in a
case like this do you agree
oh for god's sake it still didn't work
you see it faked it out look something's
wrong here
what are you complaining about the fact
that these things don't touch
the fact that there's a there's a
virtual circle image
image padding and other additional
things which when we generate it from
that yeah which we can't do which we
cannot do
and then it just gets screws up
completely right so that's wrong
so but if
we could make
look if vertex shape worked correctly
and had a special name
which would be nice if it was automatic
but that's you know maybe it's name i
don't know
then we have then we might have
something reasonable here
i don't understand why this isn't a
different setting for vertex label like
you know
inline name or something because vertex
label doesn't address there's two things
here there's the appearance of the
vertex and there is how the vertex is
labeled
okay look at this but
my claim is that vertex shape goes to
name is wrong because
the shape of the vertex you see it's
with the label that goes inside of it
okay but but look look at this case here
okay
right i'm saying i'm saying that vertex
label needs uh
and and maybe vertex label can't control
this well enough but
um
maybe
right inline name will also resize the
the shape around it right the vertex
shape
is goes to automatic and then you
specify
uh you know vertex name goes to
you know inline
label or inline name or something like
that vertex label goes to inline name
then vertex the vertex shape should
resize to properly enclose the
the delay yeah i mean there's not even
listen i have to run unfortunately but
um uh
to be maybe you guys can do you want to
continue i mean maybe you guys can make
progress on this
i need to go
i mean i see the problem we'll try to
figure that out
okay all right
thanks guys see you later
you